hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
30 years old i have a 20 million pound
net worth and i own a lot of properties
i own a castle and in this video i
wanted to answer the question i get
asked all the time which is how did i
get started how did i get started in
property aged 17 years old so if you're
interested in hearing my story then stay
listening and if you're thinking about
getting into property yourself maybe you
don't have a lot of money you're not
you're from a family of property
investors then maybe you'll get some in
interesting information and the golden
nuggets from this short video so the
first thing i want to say is when i
started out in property i just read a
few books inspirational motivational
books
from people like robert kiyosaki i read
a book called rich dad poor dad i read a
book called screw it let's do it by
richie branson and i remember reading
these books and i was i was just
finishing school
and i remember just thinking these guys
that are writing these books
they didn't do that well in school
which was for me a massive inspiration
because as i was finishing school and
i've just done my exams i was thinking
i'm not really cut out for this
academically
my exams i didn't do super well and i
wasn't particularly good in school so as
i was finishing school i was going down
the labouring type jobs i was doing a
bit of work for my dad i was working as
a plasterer i'd been just done some work
on a building site
all physical kind of jobs where you're
trading your time for money because i
thought going to university getting a
job working up the academic world that
really wasn't for me but what i realized
reading these books is there's a whole
third way
we always think in terms of at school
you can either use your hands and do
something practical or you can use your
brain and do something academic like be
a doctor or a lawyer or a builder
or an accountant or a driver
and what i realized is when i was a
teenager just as i was leaving school
reading these books is that there's a
whole third way and the third way is
being an entrepreneur the third way is
by being a business owner an
investor so i thought this is awesome
so i looked on google and i found some
property investment and business
meetings i found networking events
business networking international
property investors network i joined a
network marketing company called utility
warehouse and i signed up as a
distributor and i started going to these
business
entrepreneurial networks and it blew my
mind
and one of the things that really
surprised me was how a lot of people
took me seriously at school i was the
clown
in my family it was like oh you know
whereas now i'm at these business
networking events in a cheap suit and
people were like oh so what's your
strategy what people kind of believed in
me and took me seriously and i want to
give a big shout out as well to my
parents because my parents my mom my dad
and my stepdad you know although at
times
at times
my dad you know i had to leave the
family business and he wasn't
particularly happy about that when i was
like i want to be a property investor
but i want to give a shout out to my
parents and for the people in my family
who did believe in me i also want to
give a shout out to people at these
business networking events that actually
took me seriously even when i didn't
even take myself seriously because i
learned about property investment now
there's a big problem
this is where it's interesting so stay
listening
i didn't have any money
so even though i started learning about
business i had no money
so
i learned how to find property
investments but how can you be an
investor
when you don't have anything to invest
and one of the things the first really
important lesson that i learned
when i saw other people winning and i
started reading my books going to
seminars was that you don't have to have
money to invest yourself
to be a successful business owner or
property investor in fact most of the
people that are making a lot of money
even the banks
when the banks make money from property
investing they don't use their money
they use your money
and i thought all these rich people
they're tapping into other people's
money i can do the same
so just like how the banks use other
people's money to invest in property
that's crazy right the banks use your
money you save up your money and give it
to them and then they loan it out to
people at higher interest and they
invest in property and stocks crazy
that's what all rich people do so i
thought why can't i do that so my very
first property was in birmingham that i
found really good property i agreed to
buy for a hundred thousand pounds it was
worth 120. this was in 2009
and i borrowed
100 of the finance to buy this property
i got money from um from from the bank i
raised money
i couldn't get the mortgage because i
was too young and my stepdad tim
who i love for everyone ever and ever
agreed to basically be like a host of
this property and it was in trust for me
and i purchased this property using my
step dad's financial credit i used his
credit
and i used other people's and the bank's
money i found the property and i
purchased this when i was 17.
i then rented this property out room by
room
and lived off of the rent i'm like man
this is crazy um my second property that
i bought
i bought it on i got a 75
mortgage and i borrowed money off of an
investor for the deposit and i 100
i used other people's money i started
building a portfolio using other
people's money
i bought a property in 2010
on a buy now
pay later philosophy so this wasn't
borrowing someone else's money this was
stalling the payment but in the meantime
i'm getting the rent
so when i'm like 18 19 i'm getting all
this rent coming in i'm like man this is
nice because you don't have to actually
work to get rent but you just need the
property you rent it outside all this
rent coming in passive income
this is incredible and then the
properties in 2010 2011 after the crash
what happened they started booming the
values started shooting up when the
values went up
i'm making loads of money did i sell the
properties no i kept them i refinanced
them so i got a new more i borrowed
against them and i snowballed my
portfolio
and basically i'm now 30 and i'm in a
lot of debt
i've got millions of pounds worth of
debt but most high net worth individuals
are also high debt worth individuals so
although i've got a lot of debt i've
also got a lot of net and my passive
income is very high
and i make a lot of money
and that's how i got started in property
and where am i going now i guess now i'm
in development i'm buying pieces of land
i'm building houses from scratch and
i've also got this youtube channel to
help people get started in property
and i hope this video was helpful if it
was hit the like button drop a comment
below and i'll see you next time
[Music]